This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。在这个光怪陆离的现代世界里，我将为你剖析精神韧性、体能以及如何培养适应力。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。即T-W-O。百分之二。欢迎收听《Look Back at it》播客。1979年对我来说是一个重大时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J，我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯带来的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行其他任何地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你们是在和一个懂得他在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要使用它。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Alesspian. Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生了一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。埃伦女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。迈克尔·兰吉尼。我简直惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and trends. transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners,
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《二三十岁心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二三十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理学意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众，
old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. It's a bit of a different episode today. It's a chit chat, catch up with me, kind of episode. Because, because it's kind of been a while since I've just popped myself in front of the microphone and talked about my life, Gemma's life. What's been happening? What's been happening behind the scenes of the psychology of your 20s? I always feel a little bit weird doing these life updates, doing these like chatty episodes because I feel like that's not what you're really here for. perhaps I feel like you expect more from me sometimes like you expect the fully researched
老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听新的一期节目，当然，我们要剖析二十多岁的心理学。今天的节目有点不同。这是一期闲聊、叙旧类型的节目。因为，因为我已经有一段时间没有坐在麦克风前谈论我的生活、杰玛的生活了。发生了什么？在《二三十岁心理学》的幕后都发生了什么？我总觉得做这些生活更新、做这种闲聊类型的节目有点奇怪，因为我觉得这并不是你真正来这里的目的。也许我觉得有时你对我有更多的期望，就像你期望得到完全深入研究的
fully fleshed out episodes and not delivering on that it's like not delivering on a promise and people are going to be disappointed that it's just me and my personality and no science but trying to get over that a little bit I also just think that that's my toxic productivity you know I release two episodes a week one of them every now and again can just be me getting to talk about myself and my learnings and how my beliefs and my life is changing. I'm actually reading this book right now called The Ambition Trap. I cannot remember who it's by, but it's called The Ambition Trap. And it's completely like fundamentally changed how I'm viewing work and productivity, specifically how I'm viewing perfection and allowing myself to make
内容充实的节目，而没有做到这一点就像没有兑现承诺，人们会感到失望，因为这只是我和我的个性，没有任何科学依据，但我要稍微克服这一点。我也只是认为这是我有毒的生产力，你知道的，我一周发布两期节目，其中一期偶尔可以只谈谈我自己和我的心得，以及我的信仰和生活是如何改变的。我最近其实在读一本书叫《野心陷阱》。我不记得是谁写的了，但它叫《野心陷阱》。它彻底地、根本性地改变了我看待工作和生产力的方式，特别是看待完美主义的方式，并允许自己犯下
mistakes and not even make mistakes, but allowing myself to have fun with my job and to have fun with my life. And something I'm really aiming for at the moment is trying to measure my life more by how I feel, what I can do for others, whether I feel creative, whether I'm patient, whether I have the capacity for patience and the capacity for kindness and how I'm taking care of myself. And this is kind of an effort to do that, to just sit down and talk rather than feel like I owe people something. So anyways, a long-winded way of saying, hello, welcome. Today we're going to talk about what's been going on in my life. You may remember, maybe almost a year ago, I would say seven months, I did another little chatty episode, what's been going on with me. And it was very, very different
错误，甚至不是犯错，而是允许自己在工作中获得乐趣，在生活中获得乐趣。我目前真正追求的目标是，试着更多地通过我的感受、我能为他人做些什么、我是否感到有创造力、我是否有耐心、我是否有耐心的容量和善良的容量，以及我如何照顾自己来衡量我的生活。这也是为了做到这一点而付出的一种努力，就是坐下来聊天，而不是觉得我欠别人什么。不管怎样，用冗长的话来说就是，你好，欢迎。今天我们要聊聊我的生活一直在发生什么。你可能还记得，差不多一年前，我想是七个月前，我做了另一个小闲聊节目，聊聊我最近在经历什么。这和我平时聊的内容非常非常不同。
to what I normally talk about. It was me essentially giving you the details behind my mental breakdown. Let's call it what it is. It was a mental breakdown. I was in such a dark and raw place and I was honestly so deeply detached from who I am and I felt so awful and detached from the world and from reality. And I was just a complete mess. And I feel like I kind of released that. episode. I felt very brave doing it. And then I just went back to like my regularly scheduled programming and it didn't really acknowledge it again, probably because so much happened afterwards. You know, I announced my book probably a month or two after I released that episode. So then I just got so caught up in, you know, promoting person in progress. Then I launched my new podcast
它本质上是我在向你讲述我精神崩溃背后的细节。实话实说吧。那就是一次精神崩溃。我当时处于一个非常黑暗和痛苦的境地，说实话，我深深地脱离了真实的自我，我感到非常糟糕，与世界和现实脱节了。我简直一团糟。我觉得我发布了那一集节目。做这件事时我感到非常勇敢。然后我又回到了我常规的节目安排中，没有真正再次承认它，可能是因为后来发生了太多事情。你知道的，大概在我发布那一集节目的一两个月后，我宣布了我的书。然后我就忙于宣传《人生进度中》。然后我推出了我的新播客
mantra. So then I got so caught up in launching mantra because I love it and because it's incredible. And then the book came out and then I had to promote the book coming out. And from the outside, you would definitely have this perception, or maybe not, but I think that there would be this perception that this last year of my life has been like amazing and incredible and I must be on such a high. And I'm not really. There's definitely elements of it in which I'm very happy and in which my life is getting exceedingly better. But there has been a lot of misery, I guess, a lot of silence struggling, like behind the scenes that, you know what, we need to talk about because what you see online isn't real.
《Mantra》。然后我就忙于推出《Mantra》，因为我喜欢它，因为它太不可思议了。然后书出版了，然后我不得不宣传书的出版。从外表上看，你肯定会有这种看法，或者也可能没有，但我认为会有这样一种看法，即我过去这一年的生活一定棒极了、不可思议，我一定处于高光时刻。而我其实并没有。其中确实有让我非常高兴、生活变得越来越好的元素。但我猜也有很多痛苦，有很多默默的挣扎，比如幕后发生的事情，你知道吗，我们需要谈论它，因为你在网上看到的并不是真的。
What you hear on podcasts isn't always real. What you think about someone else's life isn't real. And as much as I love talking about our 20s and I love talking about psychology, I think my real passion is just talking about the vulnerable things that make us human. And part of that is being open just sitting here and saying, hey, like, there has been some things I've been really, that have been really hard in my life recently and you wouldn't have any clue. So let's talk about it.
你在播客中听到的并不总是真的。你对别人生活的看法并不是真的。尽管我喜欢谈论我们的二十多岁，喜欢谈论心理学，但我真正的热情其实是谈论那些让我们成为人类的脆弱的事情。其中一部分就是敞开心扉，坐在里说，嘿，比如，我最近生活中有一些真的很难熬的事情，而你对此一无所知。所以我们来聊聊吧。
Despite all of that, and I will obviously give you updates on what I'm talking about, um, life is slowly getting really, really good. And I feel like I've had some really incredible epiphanies and mindset, shifts and just like radical, I've just experienced some radical acceptance about unchangeable things in life. And when you have those kinds of radical moments and transformative moments, like, you just kind of want to scream it from the rooftop and just say to people like, it gets better. Like, it's going to get better. I've had a really tough year. I felt very ungrateful and guilty for not being able to enjoy my moments as much as I wish I had been able
尽管经历了这一切——我显然会向你们更新我正在谈论的事情——生活正在慢慢变得非常非常好。我觉得我有一些非常不可思议的顿悟、思维转变，以及对生活中无法改变的事情产生了彻底的、仅仅是彻底的接纳。当你经历那种彻底的时刻和变革时刻时，你就会有一种从屋顶上大喊大叫的冲动，只想告诉人们一切都会好起来的。就像，一切都会好起来的。我度过了非常艰难的一年。我为自己没能像希望的那样充分享受当下的时刻而感到非常不知感恩和内疚。但经历这一切——就像有一些非常不可思议的领悟，我认为它们对我来说是改变人生的。所以这就是我们今天要聊的内容。我们要聊聊为什么有时情况在变好之前必须先变糟，挣扎意味着什么，繁荣意味着什么，作为一个该死的人意味着什么。闲话少说，让我们进入简短的生活更新吧。所以目前在播客的幕后，我一直在经历这些，我一直在真正建立这样一个全新的、深刻的信念系统。我觉得去年我之所以精神崩溃，原因其实很存在主义。对于那些不知道的人来说，我成长的时候，我曾经是一个，我曾经过着非常深刻的信仰生活。我的家人并不信教。
to. But throughout at all, like there are some really incredible learnings that I think a life changing for me. So that's what we're going to talk about today. We're going to talk about why sometimes it has to get worse before it gets better, what it means to struggle, what it means to thrive, what it means to be freaking human. Without further ado, let's get into a little life update. So behind the scenes of the podcast at the moment, I have been going through it and I've been really building like this very whole new deep belief system. I feel like the real real. I feel like the reason I had this mental breakdown last year was quite existential. For those of you who don't know, like when I was growing up, I used to be, I used to have a really deep faith. My family was not religious.
我们从不去教堂。他们可以说是无神论者。但不知为何，我总是觉得自己被召唤去加入有组织的信仰。所以，在我的青少年时期，绝对是在我十几岁的晚期，可能是我二十出头的头几年里，我总是感觉到这种真正更高层面的召唤，以及一种与宗教相连的生活意义感。然后，我想我从来没有谈过这个，但我经历了一些事情，我不想称之为创伤，
We never went to church. They were about as atheist as it comes. But for some reason, I always really felt called into like organized religion. And so like for a lot of my teen years and like definitely just my late teen years, maybe like the first year of my 20s, like I always felt this like real higher calling and the sense of like, meaning in life that was attached to religion. And then I don't think I've ever talked about this, but I went through something, I don't want to call it traumatic,
但只是在我和我约会的一个人交往期间，与我所在的教堂发生了一些非常令人沮丧和不安的事情。我再也没有回去过。当时我就想，不，我真的再也受不了了。这完全打破了我的信仰结构。然后有一段时间，就像是一种，我的灵魂里出现了一个空洞，
but just like really frustrating and disturbing with the church that I was in involving someone I was dating. And I just never went back. Like, I was just like, no, I just can't do this anymore. Like, I just, it just completely like broke my belief structure. And then for a while there was just kind of like this, there was just this whole, I guess, like in my soul where I, all these big questions that
信仰真正为我填补的那些宏大的问题，我找不到答案了。我们是为了什么来到这里的？爱的意义是什么？这是一个充满敌意还是充满爱的宇宙？公平意味着什么？正义意味着什么？这些事情我其实都没有答案。我觉得去年这一切都达到了顶峰，当时我想，噢，我对这些事情真的没有答案。这其实真的很吓人。我得想清楚自己想相信什么。我必须通过我自己的方式、通过灵性、通过科学、通过哲学，无论是什么能够引导我到达那里的东西，来弄清楚我在这个世界上的位置是什么。还有其他一些事情也在发生。这真的把我推到了一个如此低谷的境地，仅仅是思考世界的荒谬性。通过那段经历我真正学到了什么，老实说，我觉得过去的一个月是我自去年事情发生以来真正第一次从阴影中走出来。就像这最后一个月，我真的有了一种那种时刻，天哪，我现在开始懂了，而且我很开心，哇，生活太美好了。
faith really filled for me, like I didn't have answers to. Like, what are we here for? What's the meaning of love? Is this a hostile or a loving universe? Like, what does fairness mean? What does justice mean? Like, I didn't really have answers for those things. And I feel like that all kind of came to a head last year when I was like, oh, I really don't have answers for these things. and that's actually really scary. And I have to kind of figure out what I want to believe in. And I have to figure out what I see my place in this world is like through my own means and through spirituality, through science, through philosophy, whatever it was that was going
我觉得我是一个非常乐观的人，以至于去年的大部分时间和今年年初，我都觉得生活是由痛苦和折磨定义的。我终于能够欣赏奇迹般的存在了。这就像是我作为一个非常乐观的人真正珍视的东西，我必须看到世界美好的一面。所以我很高兴这种心态正在回到我身边。但它真正提醒我的是，黎明前总是最黑暗的，有时真正的成长确实来自于痛苦，
to guide me there. And there was some other things going on as well. And it really like pushed me to such a low place, just thinking about the absurdity of the world. And what I really learned through that, and I honestly feel like the last month has been the first time that I've really come out of it since like it happened last year. Like it's this last month I've really been having like a moment of like, oh my God, like I'm getting things now and like I'm happy and wow, like life is beautiful.
而且你能承受的远比你想象的要多。我记得听到别人这么说时，心想，你在说什么呢？你在胡说八道什么？然后，我所经历的精神上的那种斗争，一次又一次地向我证明了这一点，证明了我有多坚强，我有多有韧性。我还想谈谈其他一些正在发生的事情。所以，我根本没有谈过这个，但在我的书发布前夕，我去了验光师那里，很偶然。我需要配副新眼镜。
And I feel like I'm such an optimistic person that I spent so much of last year and the start of this year feeling like life was defined by misery and suffering. And I've finally been able to appreciate like the miracle of existence. And that's like something that I really. value as such an optimistic person, I have to see the good in the world. So I'm glad that that is coming back to me. But what it's really reminded me of is like, it's just continually reminded me that it's always darkest before the dawn, that sometimes true growth does come from suffering and
当我在验光师那里时，他们发现了一些非常吓人的东西。在我的，叫什么来着，视神经上，视神经，抱歉。我当时只是在进行一次例行的、例行安排的眼科预约。这位验光师在查看我做过的这些视网膜图像。我做这个检查纯属偶然。我当时根本没注意。前台的工作人员问，哦，你想做这个检查吗？我就说，好啊，好啊。
that you can endure so much more than you think you can. And I remember like hearing people say that and being like, what are you talking about? Like, what are you on about? and then like the mental kind of battle that I've been through is just proven that to me time and time again, like how strong I am, how resilient I am. I also want to talk about some other things that have been happening. So I haven't talked about this at all, but right before my book was launched, I went into the optometrist, random. I needed to get new glasses.
然后我又想，哦，我真的想做这个检查吗？但我已经答应了。所以她正在看这些照片。她基本上说，哦，你得了，我不会说这是什么，或者也许我会说。基本上就像是它在肿胀。而且它就在视神经周围，这是一个非常非常不好的迹象。在大概20个小时内，我想是48小时内，我就在一个专家那里做所有这些测试。他们必须排除的事情真的很吓人。他们必须排除多发性硬化症（MS）。他们必须排除脑瘤。他们必须排除所有这些真的
And when I was at the optometrist, they like found something really scary. on my, what's it called, optical nerve, optic nerve, sorry. And I was in just like a regular schedule, regularly scheduled, like eye appointment. And this optometrist, like, was looking at these like retinal images that I had gotten done. And it was so random that I'd gotten them done. I wasn't paying attention. And the person at the front desk was like, oh, do you want these done? And I was like, yeah, yeah.
很吓人的事情，我当时并没有中风。在48小时内，这就好像，哦，我的视力、我的大脑正在发生一件大事。这太吓人了。我在眼科医生的办公室里。在我发现自己得了这个我字面上一无所知的东西48小时后。我记得我当时还算镇定，突然他们开始放大我的瞳孔，我不知道你有没有经历过这种事，但他们把一种东西滴进你的眼里，让你的瞳孔变得巨大。然后你在接下来的四个小时里什么也看不见。我坐在那里想，就在他们把药水滴进我眼睛的时候，我想，天哪。这说明我身上正在发生一件大事。这真的很吓人，我才刚刚开始消化它。
And then I was like, oh, do I really want those done? But I'd already said yes. So she was looking at these photos. And she basically was like, oh, you have, I'm not going to say. what it is, or maybe I will. Like, basically it was like that it's swelling. And it's all around the optic nerve, which is a really, really bad sign. And within like 20, I think like 48 hours, I was like at a specialist doing all these tests. The things they had to rule out were really scary. They had to rule out MS. They had to rule out a brain tumor. They had to rule out all these really
所以他们试图把这些眼药水滴进我的眼里，我当时在哭，我歇斯底里。我的男朋友也在那里说，我知道这太吓人了。不管怎样，事实是，对于到底发生了什么，我仍然没有任何答案。这简直是，我正在努力理清时间线，就在我的书发布、我的书问世前几周。突然间就变成这样，哦，天哪，发生什么事了？我们仍在努力弄清楚。不得不做所有这些检查，不得不做所有这些核磁共振，不得不做所有
scary things that I wasn't having stroke. Within 48 hours, like, it was like, oh, this huge thing is happening with my vision, with my brain. Like, that's so scary. And I was in, like, the ophthalmologist's office. 48 hours after I found out I had this thing that I literally don't know, knew nothing about. And I remember I, like, kept my cool and then suddenly they were dilating my pupil, which I don't know if you've ever had this happen, but they put this stuff in your eye that makes your pupil go huge. And then you can't see for like the next four hours. And I was sitting there and I was like, and why does they were putting it in my eye? I was like, oh my gosh. Like this is something huge is happening to me. Like this is really scary and I've only just started processing it.
这些血液检查。这真的、真的很吓人。问题是，那是生活变得更糟的时候。我当时还有所有这些其他的事情在发生。然后就变成了，砰，健康恐慌。而且，你知道，砰，生活是脆弱的。以防你需要这个提醒。这压力太大了。
So they're trying to put these like drops in my eye and I'm like crying and I'm like hysterical. And like my boyfriend's there being like, I know it's so scary. And anyways, The thing is, is that I still don't have any answers around what's going on. This was literally, I'm trying to get the timeline right, like, very, like, within weeks before my book was launching, before my book was coming out. And suddenly it was just like, oh, my God, what is happening? And we're still trying to figure it out. Just having to get all these tests done, having to get all these MRIs, having to get all
我现在笑得出来，尽管，我觉得既然我知道我没有长什么重大的脑瘤，而且我现在绝对知道我没有中风，我可以笑对这一切了。但当时的情况可以说是命悬一线，事实上，验光师在我离开后给我打了电话，因为她之前说过，哦，最终去看医生吧。然后她给我打了大约六次电话说，嘿，这其实是个紧急情况。那真的很吓人。现在我感觉好多了。
this blood work. And it's been really, really scary. And the thing is, is that that was life getting worse. Like, I had all this other stuff going on. And then it was like, and bam, health scare. And, you know, and bam, like, life is fragile. Like, just in case you needed that reminder. And it was incredibly stressful.
我觉得那真的是低谷。也有人问我，在我的书问世之前，我的心理健康状况如何？我，你们可能知道，我试图戒掉我的药物。我一直在吃来士普。我去年试图戒掉，不幸的是效果非常非常不好。今年我实际上已经减量到10毫克了。这并不是医疗建议。我只是喜欢公开谈论剂量和一切，因为这可能对你们有所帮助。
Like, I'm laughing about it now, even though, like, I think now that I know I don't have, like, a significant brain tumor, and now that I definitely know that I wasn't having a stroke, I can laugh about it. But like it was kind of touch and go there and actually like the optometrist like called me after I'd left because she'd been like, oh, just go to the doctor eventually. And then she'd called me like six times and was like, hey, like this is actually an emergency. So that was scary. Now I feel fine.
我觉得我对它的依赖越来越少，但它对我来说是一个安全网，对吧？我本来想说我知道自己永远不会陷入真正的低谷，但显然我可以，不过那是我当时没有服药的时候。这只是对我来说一个很好的安全网。这就好像，好吧，我知道我的抑郁和焦虑是生理性的。我知道这一点。我每周锻炼四到五次。
And I feel like that was really the low point. I also had some people asking me like how was my mental health leading up to my book coming out? And I, so you guys might know, I tried to go off my medication. I'm on Lexapro. I tried to go off last year and it didn't go very, very well, unfortunately. This year I have actually tapered down to 10 milligrams. And I like, this is not medical advice. I just like to talk openly about dosages and everything because just might be helpful
我吃得很好。我在户外度过很多时间。我有充满爱的家庭、社会联系。我有一个有目标的职业。我是安全的。我所有的需求都得到了满足，甚至还有多余的，我能够回馈社会。就像我在做所有人所说的事实上能防范抑郁和焦虑的事情。而且，你知道，我在做人们总是说有帮助的行为干预，但它们不起作用。所以我知道这是生理性的，而且我认为拥有这种干预真的非常非常有益。所以这就是药物更新的一种。
to you. And I feel like I need it less and less, but it is such a safety net for me, right? I was going to say I know I could never get to a really low point, but obviously I could, but that was when I wasn't taking it. It's just a nice safety net for me. It's just like, okay, I know that my depression and my anxiety is biological. I know that. I exercise like four to five times a week.
但是的，在我的书出版之前，我一直在挣扎。不仅因为我遇到了那个健康恐慌的事情，那是一件大事，还因为我生活中发生了很多其他重大变化，我不得不在书出版的前一天搬家，这也是两件大事同时发生。而且关于写书，他们可能不会告诉你的一件事是，它是相当反高潮的，对吧，所以你付出了很多工作，写一本书需要那么多小时和你那么多的心血，然后这一切都在某一天水落石出，在那之后，这太奇怪了，你
I eat really well. I spend a lot of time outdoors. I have loving family, social connection. I have a purposeful goal. career. I'm safe. I have all my needs met and then some I'm able to give back. Like I'm doing all the things that people say are externally protective against depression and anxiety. And, you know, I'm doing all the behavioral interventions that people always say as helping and they didn't work. So I know that it's biological and I think just having this kind of intervention has been really, really useful. So that's
不再真正听到很多与你合作过的人的消息，你突然就有点孤立无援了，你突然就觉得，好吧，我只能靠自己了，这本书就在这里，你知道，它是公开的，它接受公众的意见，你需要人们去买它，而你真的不知道该怎么做。而且你也会面对生活中的失望，比如你生命中的人不支持你，你生命中的人在一个重大时刻没有真正为你出现，没有买书，或者，你知道，没有说祝贺的话，或者一些小事。我前几天对某人说，你知道那句名言吗，当你生孩子时，你知道谁是你真正的朋友。当你写书时，你也知道谁是你真正的朋友。
kind of like a medication update. But yeah, leading up to my book coming out, I was struggling. Not just because I had that health scare thing, which was significant, but because a lot of other big changes were happening in my life, I had to move house the day before my book came out as well, which was just like two huge things happening at once. And also something they may not tell you about writing a book is that it's quite anticlimactic, right so you um do a lot of work it takes so many hours and so much of you to write a book and then it all like comes to fruition on like one day and then after that like it's so weird like you don't
因为我不知道。我觉得我是那种朋友，当别人做这样酷的事情时，我都会全力支持。看到对你来说是大事的事情并不一定对其他人也是大事，这很有趣。所以我想如果我当时处于更好的精神状态，并且在书出版前没有遇到重大的健康恐慌，我本可以更好地放下那些事情，但这真的是一场挣扎。所以，有这样一个奇怪的低谷高峰，当时我想，哇，巨大的职业里程碑。同时又觉得，哦，天哪，我的生活到底怎么了？这就是我想谈论事情如何变好的时候。
really hear from a lot of the people that you've worked with like you're suddenly just kind of on your own um and you're suddenly just like okay i have to do i'm just on my own like this book is here and you know, it's open, it's open for public opinion and you need people to buy it and you don't really know how to do that. And you also like will face disappointments in terms of people in your life not supporting you and people in your life, yeah, not really showing up for you at a big moment and not buying copies or, you know, not saying congratulations or like small things. I was saying to someone the other day, like, you know, the quote that's like, you know who your real friends are when you have a baby. You also know who your real friends are when you write a book
就像这一集的中心思想是，情况在变好之前会先变糟。对我来说，情况可能会变得更糟得多。让我们完全现实一点。说实话，与现在世界上许多人正在经历的事情相比，我当时经历的根本不算什么。但情况确实变好了。然后这些变化慢慢地开始在我的生活中发生。我觉得我一直在这个候诊室里。
because I don't know. I feel like I'm the kind of friend where people do cool things like that. I'm like really all behind it. And it was interesting seeing how big things for you don't necessarily translate to big things for other people. So I think if I had been in a better mental state and hadn't had a big health scare right before my book came out, I would have been able to let those things go a little bit better, but it was a real struggle. So, there was like a weird low point high point where I was like, wow, huge career milestone. Also like, oh my God, what is going on in my life? This is when I want to talk about how things get better.
我觉得我经历了一场所谓的灵魂黑夜。突然间，有人打开门说，好吧，酷。你已经做够了。你在这里坐了足够长的时间。我们看得出你能承受。欢迎来到你人生的下一篇章。我想用这集的最后一部分来谈谈那种感觉是什么样的，以及我对我现在所处的位置是多么感激，以及
Like the theme of this episode is things get worse before they get better. Things could have gotten a whole lot worse to me. Let's be completely real. Like, honestly, what I was going through is nothing compared to what so many people around the world are going through right now. But things got worse. And then slowly these changes started in my life. and I felt like I had been in this waiting room.
我感激的是什么。所以留下来。和我在一起。我想告诉你为什么情况总会好起来。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将为你剖析精神韧性、体能以及如何在这个光怪陆离的现代世界中培养适应力。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话。看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。
I felt like I had gone through the dark night of the soul, as they call it. And suddenly someone like opened the door and was like, all right, cool. You've like done enough. Like you've sat here for long enough. We can tell you can take it. Welcome to the next chapter of your life. And I want to spend the next part of this episode talking about what that felt like and how grateful I am for where I am now and what.
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更 healthier 的人。请收听《2%》。即T-W-O-Persent。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。你在玩愚蠢的游戏，你就会得到愚蠢的奖励。规则二，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。
what it is that I'm grateful for. So stick around. Stay with me. I want to tell you why it always gets better. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more. to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这个新季的《闺蜜》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都中了招。同一个多产的骗子。我觉得我被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上。警察似乎并不在意。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app. Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either.
所以她们决定自己动手。我说，哦，见鬼，不。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts中，
We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all done. The same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care.
或者在任何你收听播客的地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上双重拍打小金的屁股吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。
So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts,
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的快克。需要说明的是，84年对我的意义重大，不仅因为快克。我随时准备谈论快克，
or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-taped little Kim's boo at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
是的，是的。字面意思。但为了让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we picket here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day,
这里有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆上台面了。所以。谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？
Yeah, yeah. Literally. But just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed, correct. So I'm starting to see
是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。
that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. So. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
欢迎来到我的新播客。《Learn the Hardway》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。我们还在追逐它，而且我们不知道什么时候已经做够了。因为人们在看记分牌。
Welcome to my new podcast. Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking.
生活变成了赢与输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世时做一个好人很重要？还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两个不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。
Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
打开你免费的iHeartRadio App。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。所以这是第一件改变我生活并让我摆脱非常黑暗时期的事情。我寄养了一只狗。你们可能知道那只寄养狗不再是我的寄养狗了。它现在是我的亲狗了。但我一开始是寄养这只狗的。她的名字叫塔露，因为我在RSPCA网站上看到了她。
Life becomes about wins and loss. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway.
我不知道是什么原因。当时我就想，我需要帮助这只狗。我需要她在我的生活中。比如，我有空间。我有容量。我有时间。我有，好吧，我当时的房子不允许养狗，但不管怎样，我想办法解决了。就像，我只是觉得有一种召唤去拯救她。
Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. So this was the first thing that transformed my life and has gotten me out of a very dark period. I fostered a dog. And you guys might know that that foster is no longer my foster dog. It's now my actual dog. But I started out fostering this dog. Her name is Talu because I saw her on the RSPCA website.
我们把她带回家，大概在两天内，我和我的伴侣汤姆就想，哦，糟糕。糟糕，我们这次真的、真的搞砸了。因为这只狗是个大甜心。她太聪明了。她太善良了。她太渴望被爱了，太渴望成为这个群体的一部分了。我们对彼此说，在做决定之前，我们必须给她三个月的期限。
and I just don't know what it was. I was like, I need to help this dog. I need her in my life. Like, I have space. I have capacity. I have time. I have, well, my house at the time did not allow dogs, but whatever I got around that. Like, I just felt this calling to go and rescue her.
如果在三个月内没有人领养她，我们可以考虑。这并没有持续多久。一个月后我们就领养了她。养一只狗确实有些东西能改变你的视角。它让你变得更无私。它让你更有耐心。你通过他们的眼睛看生活。我觉得我在重温许多其他人已经发现的事情。
And we brought her home and within like two days, me and my partner, Tom, were like, oh, uh-oh. Uh-oh, like really, really screwed up here. because this dog is the biggest sweetheart. She is so smart. She is so kind. She just so wants to be loved and she just so wants to be part of the pack. And we said to each other, we have to give it three months before deciding.
但天哪，这真是太棒了。就像每天早晨我醒来都必须带她出去，必须带她去散步。这意味着我在户外的时间更多了，我必须为她做这些事情，即使我不想，即使我很忙，即使我心情不好。生活已经变成围绕着她。老实说，我认为这倒不是一种分心，但我认为这是让我摆脱自我所需的东西。比如，我觉得我真的在投资于这样一种自我概念，即自己正在承受苦难。当时我想，哦，生活真的很艰难，我在尽力而为，但它不管用。然后我救了她，而她的历史
And if nobody has adopted her in three months, we can consider it. That did not last very long. We adopted her after a month. and there's just something around having a dog that changes your perspective. It makes you so much more selfless. It makes you more patient. You see life through it through their eyes. I feel like I'm rehashing what so many other people have discovered.
太糟糕了。比如她，是的，曾遭受过非常严重的虐待，然后被带走，就像被强行带走一样，有人进来救了她。然后那些救她的人把RSPCA告上法庭，想要把她要回去。所以这意味着她必须在收容所待一年，然后才被允许离开收容所进行探访什么的。我不知道。我当时就想，哇，我的生活可能糟糕得多。这里有这个美丽的动物，这个美丽的生物，你知道的，她的鼻子上有烧伤，少了几颗牙齿，有一个如此艰难的开端。而她该死地热爱生活。她随时准备玩耍。她被允许在草地上打滚的每一刻都是美好的时刻。早餐是一天中最美好的事情。她醒来并在床上享受20分钟的拥抱，因为当然，我们太心软了，我们允许她上床睡觉。这真的是脱胎换骨的。现在我一直对人们说，如果你在社交方面挣扎，如果你在
But oh my Lord, it was just so glorious. Like every single morning I wake up and I have to take her outside and I have to take her for a walk. And it's meant that I'm outdoors more and I have to, do these things for her, even if I don't want to, even if I'm busy, even if I'm in a bad mood. Life has become about her. And honestly, I think that it was not the distraction, but I think it was the thing I needed to get myself out of my ego. Like, I feel like I was really investing in this, like, idea of myself as like being, being, like, suffering. And I was like, oh, life is really hard and I'm trying my best and it's not working. And then I rescued her and her history.
对生活保持乐观方面挣扎，如果你在看到小事中的喜悦方面挣扎，去寄养一只狗。如果你不能领养一只狗，去寄养一只狗或者领养一只狗，看看它是如何彻底改变你的生活的。显然，比如，确保你处于一个好的空间。
is so terrible. Like she, yeah, was really badly abused and then was removed, like was forcibly removed, like someone came in and rescued her. And then the people who they rescued her from, like took the RSPCA to court and wanted to get her back. And like, so that meant she had to stay in the pound for a year before she was even allowed to go out of the pound and do visits and stuff. And I don't know. I was just like, wow, my life could be so much worse. And here is this beautiful animal, this beautiful creature who, you know, has a burn on her nose and is missing teeth and had such a hard start. And she freaking loves life. And she is like down to play. And every moment that she is allowed like to roll around in the grass is a beautiful moment. And breakfast is the best thing
我觉得我们没有仓促行事。我们非常专注，比如我们现在能养宠物吗？事情就这样顺理成章地解决了。她进入我的生活，老实说，我觉得那是宇宙赐予的礼物。然后我开始看一个新的治疗师，那也很不可思议，因为我觉得我在老治疗师那里遇到了瓶颈。她很棒，但我只是觉得我已经达到了，听起来很奇怪。我达到了我愿意与她分享的极限。我非常担心被触发，实际上，也担心治疗师说一些我没有考虑过的事情并真正让我心烦意乱，以至于我没有向她透露更多信息。我觉得，因为我过去没有向她透露这些事情，她会指责我几乎在撒谎，比如在我并不好的时候说我很好。所以我需要一缕新鲜的空气。于是我去找了一个新的治疗师，一个存在主义治疗师，她真的太棒了，并且真正向我揭示了我所挣扎的很多事情其实只是对未知的恐惧，而我所挣扎的很多事情只是我大脑运作方式的不同。而且我也开始跑步了。我，我只是把这个放着。
of every day. And she wakes up and gets 20 minutes of cuddles in the bed because of course, we're such softies, we allow her in the bed. And it's just really transformative. And now I keep saying to people, like if you struggle with socializing, if you struggle, um, with feeling optimistic about life, if you struggle to see the joy in little things, foster a dog. If you can't adopt a dog, foster a dog or adopt a dog and just see how it completely changes your life. Obviously, like, make sure that you are in a good space.
我觉得我的生活变得非常沉迷于工作以及沉迷于我还能做多少事情。你知道的，我在做，我仍在做《二三十岁心理学》。我还在我的另一个播客《Mantra》中做节目，那里有更多关于精神层面的讨论，我都非常喜欢它们。但这需要动用很多脑力。创造两件你真正热爱的事情并宣传一本书以及所有这些其他的活动需要消耗大量的精神能量。
Like, I feel like we didn't rush into it. We were really concentrated around, like, can we have a pet right now? And it just happened to work out. But the introduction of her into my life, I honestly feel like was a gift for. the universe. Then I started seeing a new therapist and that was also incredible because I feel like I was getting really stuck with my old therapist. She was amazing but I just felt like I had reached it sounds weird. I reached what I was willing to share with her and I was so like deeply worried about being triggered actually and about a therapist saying something that I hadn't considered
而且我需要一些别的东西。所以我的朋友莎拉，有一天我在公园里，她正在跑步，我碰到了她，她说，你想不想陪我跑一会儿？
and really upsetting me that I wasn't revealing anything more to her and I feel I felt like because I hadn't revealed things to her in the past that she would like call me out for almost lying, like saying that I was okay when I wasn't. So I needed a fresh light. And so I went and I started seeing a new therapist, an existential therapist who was, has just been freaking amazing and has really just revealed to me how so much of what I struggle with is just a fear of the unknown and so much of what I struggle with is just my brain working differently. And I also have started running. I just, I'm just going to leave that. there. I felt like my life was becoming very much an obsession with work and an obsession with how
这让我感到非常不安，因为我没有向她透露更多的事情。我觉得，由于我过去没有向她坦白，她会指责我几乎是在撒谎，比如在我并不好的时候说我很好。所以我需要一种全新的视角。于是我开始看一个新的治疗师，一位存在主义治疗师，她真的是太棒了，向我揭示了我所挣扎的很多事情其实只是对未知的恐惧，而我所挣扎的很多事情也只是因为我的大脑运转方式不同。而且我也开始跑步了。我只想……我只想把这一点留在那里。我感觉我的生活变得非常沉迷于工作，沉迷于
much more I could do. You know, I was doing, I'm still doing the psychology of your 20s. I was also doing mantra on my other podcast where there were more spiritual discussions going on and I love them both so much. But it is a lot to put your brain into. Like it is a lot of mental energy to create two things that you really love and promote a book and do all these other activities. as well. And I needed something else. And so my friend Sarah, I was at the park one day and she was running and I ran into her and she was like, do you just want to run with me for a little bit?
我还能做多少事情。你知道的，我在做，我仍在做《二十岁心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s）。我还在我的另一个播客《Mantra》上做节目，那里有更多关于精神层面的讨论，我非常喜欢这两者。但这确实需要消耗大量的心智。把脑力投入到创作两件你真正热爱的事情、宣传一本书以及从事所有其他活动中，确实需要付出巨大的心理能量。而且我需要一些别的东西。所以有一天我在公园里，我的朋友莎拉正在跑步，我碰到了她，她问我：“你想不想陪我跑一会儿？”
And I was like, yeah, okay, I'll do that. Ever since then, I've got the bug. I've got the freaking bug. And I've been posting about it on my personal Instagram a lot and you guys have been like, what the heck, how come you are suddenly running 15 kilometers when you used to say you hated running? It's because I've been going slow. I've been going super slow. I started at a pace that was probably like a walk or a jog and now I feel like I'm actually running. And I feel like through running as well, I've also been really testing my limits. I've been testing my ability to persevere and to endure and I've showed myself how strong I am and I've taught myself patience and I've taught myself consistency. There's just all these discoveries that I'm happening around.
当时我就想，好吧，我来试试。从那以后，我就上瘾了。我真的彻底上瘾了。我经常在个人Instagram上发这方面的内容，你们就会问，天哪，为什么你以前说讨厌跑步，现在突然开始跑15公里了？那是因为我跑得很慢。我跑得超级慢。我开始的速度可能就像走步或慢跑，现在我觉得我真的在跑步。而且我觉得通过跑步，我也真的在测试自己的极限。我在测试自己坚持和忍耐的能力，我向自己展示了我是多么坚强，我教会了自己耐心，我教会了自己坚持。我周围发生了所有这些发现
the meaning of life that I'm figuring out through such simple acts, through moving my body in a way that so many other people have done for centuries, through sharing a bond with an animal, through connecting with people, through having new discussions. And I just finally feel like I'm out of this really dark cloud. Also, it's just been so wonderful to see how many of you have been reading my book. and how many of you are relating and resonating with it. I think it's been a while since I've really appreciated that I'm doing meaningful work. I think that I can be a little bit too self-deprecating.
关于生命的意义，我是通过如此简单的行为弄明白的，通过以几百年来许多其他人做过的方式活动我的身体，通过与动物分享一种纽带，通过与人建立联系，通过进行新的讨论。我终于觉得自己走出了这片黑暗的阴云。另外，看到你们中有这么多人一直在读我的书，以及你们中有多少人在与之联系并产生共鸣，真是太好了。我想我已经有一段时间没有真正感激我正在做有意义的工作了。我想我有时可能有点过于自我贬低了。
Tell me if you're the same, where I'm like, if I acknowledge that I'm good at what I do or that I care about what I do or that maybe I have something to say, people are going to immediately cut me down for that. or that's entitlement or it will be taken away from me. The moment that you feel, I guess not grateful, but the moment that you take something for granted or that you assume that you're good at something or you assume that something is safe,
告诉我你是不是也一样，我会觉得，如果我承认我很擅长我所做的事，或者我在乎我所做的事，或者也许我有什么想说的，人们会立刻为此贬低我。或者那是理所当然的，或者它会被剥夺。当你觉得——我想不是感激，而是当你把某事视为理所当然，或者你认为自己擅长某事，或者你认为某事是安全的时候，
it will be up in the air. And I just have been reminded that that's not the case, that there are people who really want you to succeed and that it's okay to just say, like, I'm good at this thing and I care about this and I put a lot of work into it. and I'm proud of it. That's not bragging. That's not even a humble brag. That's just talking about the thing that you care about. I think all of this is just to say that I'm learning so much and I'm constantly being reminded that there is a lot of darkness in the world and life is really painful
一切都会悬而未决。我刚刚被提醒，事实并非如此，有些人真的希望你成功，而且说“我很擅长这个，我在乎这个，我为此付出了很多努力，我为此感到骄傲”是完全可以的。这不是吹牛。这甚至不是谦虚地吹牛。这只是在谈论你在乎的事情。我想这一切只是想说，我学到了很多，并且不断被提醒，世界上有很多黑暗，生活有时真的很痛苦，
sometimes, but you will come out on the other side and that you have handled it all. I'm grateful for the fact that this last year hasn't been amazing internally because every single day now that I wake up and I feel good, it's this weird thing of like, oh my gosh, like, wow, what a great day. What a great day. I've been having just like incredible days and I don't know how to express it. But I guess the whole purpose of this was just really to give you a story that makes you feel optimistic about your future. And just to give you the story of the last year of my life
但你会熬过来的，而且你已经应付了这一切。我很感激过去的一年我在内心深处并不是那么完美，因为现在每天早上我醒来，感觉很好时，都会有一种奇怪的感觉，天哪，哇，真是美好的一天。真是美好的一天。我一直在过着不可思议的日子，我不知道该怎么表达。但我想这一切的真正目的只是给你讲一个让你对未来感到乐观的故事。只是把过去一年我生活的故事讲给你听
that makes you feel that if you're going through something similar, you don't feel like you're always going to be here. And maybe you've heard that a million times before. Maybe you've heard the sentiment, life gets worse before it gets better, it's not always going to last, time heals, a million times over. But I think when there's a personal story attached to it, it really gives us hope. And when I was going through it, I guess I'm still on the tail end of going through it,
让你觉得如果你正在经历类似的事情，你不会觉得这种状态会永远持续下去。也许你以前听过一百万遍了。也许你听过这样的名言：生活在变好之前会先变糟，这一切不会永远持续，时间能治愈一切，听过无数遍了。但我觉得当有一个个人故事附着在它上面时，它真的给了我们希望。当我经历它的时候，我想我还在经历它的尾声，
I just wanted to hear stories of people having hard times and persevering and knowing that you can change your mindset, you can change the way you think about your problems, you can get yourself unstuck, you will see a better day, you will have hope again, you will have belief again, and I don't know, it's just been a really, really nice feeling. And as I'm recording this, I am about to go to Fiji with my mom and with my auntie and with my cousin for our girls' trip. And this time last year, I was in Bali for our girls' trip last year. And I spent that whole trip basically crying and having panic attacks and just feeling so awful and so heavy and uncomfortable in my brain. and now I'm going into this trip one year later feeling not amazing but pretty remarkable
我只是想听听人们经历艰难时期并坚持不懈的故事，知道你可以改变你的心态，你可以改变你看待问题的方式，你可以让自己摆脱困境，你会看到更美好的日子，你将再次拥有希望，你将再次拥有信念，我不知道，这真是一种非常非常美好的感觉。当我录制这个节目时，我和我妈妈、我阿姨还有我表妹正要一起去斐济进行我们的女孩旅行。去年这个时候，我在巴厘岛进行我们的女孩旅行。我基本上整个旅程都在哭泣，经历恐慌发作，在我的大脑中感到非常糟糕、沉重和不舒服，而现在一年后我踏上了这段旅程，虽然感觉不算绝佳，但也相当显着
and feeling transformed and feeling like I've kind of I don't know I've I've kind of built a new part of my armor it sounds all like cliches and cheesy but that's really what I wanted to talk about today and thank you so much to you guys for supporting me I don't know if you've even noticed if anything's been different maybe you've noticed some more like existential themes in recent episodes but that's really where it's coming from and I'm hoping that I get a clean bill of health very, very soon or that at least I have an answer as to what's going on in my freaking brain and with my freaking eyeball. But I'm optimistic and I feel like life is good. I feel good. Take the good days. Love one another. Foster a dog. There you go. That's my life advice. But until next time,
并且感觉自己蜕变了，感觉自己已经——我不知道——我好像建立了我盔甲的新部分，这听起来有点陈词滥调和老套，但这确实是我今天要谈论的内容，非常感谢你们支持我。我不知道你们是否注意到有什么不同，也许你们在最近的几集里注意到了一些更具存在主义的主题，但这就是它的真正来源。我希望我能很快得到一份健康的证明，或者至少我对我的该死的大脑和该死的眼睛到底怎么了有一个答案。但我很乐观，我觉得生活很美好。感觉很好。享受美好的日子。彼此相爱。领养一只狗。就是这样。这就是我的人生建议。但直到下次，
make sure you are following me on Instagram at that psychology podcast. Thanks for sticking around for this life update. Tell me how you're going in the comments. Make this a two-way straight. I feel like I just dumped a lot of information on you if you've made it this far. Wow. Thank you for enduring all of that. And also, yeah, I want to hear what's been happening with you as well.
确保你在Instagram上关注我，账号是that psychology podcast。感谢大家收听这次的生活更新。在评论区告诉我你过得怎么样。让这成为一条双向的街道。如果你听到了这里，我觉得我刚才向你倾倒了大量的信息。哇。谢谢你坚持听完这一切。而且，是的，我也想听听你最近发生了什么。
How are we feeling out of town? What's the emoji that best represents your life right now? Make sure you are following along. Make sure that you have left us a five-star review. if you feel called to do so. And remember to take care of yourself. Remember life gets better. Remember, it is all, it's not always meant to be great.
我们离开城镇时感觉怎么样？最能代表你目前生活的表情符号是什么？确保你一直在关注。如果你觉得有必要的话，请务必给我们留下五星好评。并记得照顾好自己。记住生活会变得更好。记住，一切并不总是注定要完美的。
And it's not always going to be great, but it's always going to end up amazing. Until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness,
而且它并不总是完美的，但它最终总是会变得非常棒。直到下次，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温和一点。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中，我剖析了精神坚韧、健身的科学，
and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast.
并在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力。让自己经历一些苦难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。收听“2%”。也就是IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWA%”。在“Look Back at it”播客中。
From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down. and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
从1979年开始，这对我和来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说很重要。我是萨姆·J，我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选你在这里的内容，剖析发生了什么，并试图通过我们的朋友、喜剧演员同仁和最喜欢的作家来弄清楚我们是如何度过难关的。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代一样。那是一个疯狂的年代。那是一个疯狂的年代。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听look back at it。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听“Learn the Hard Way”
with your favorite therapist and hosts Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast,
由你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人Kear Games主持。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在AHA电台应用、Apple Podcast上收听“Learn the Hard Way”，
or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hope. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian.
或者在你获取播客的任何地方。2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生育了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you. you get your podcasts. This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是“Love Trapped”。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听“Love Trapped”播客。这是一个I-Heart播客。保证是真人。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。